resistente esta franquicia que ha pasado
por muchas fases altos y bajos pero que
a pesar de todo sigue siendo una de
nuestras franquicias favoritas y como no
serlo tiene terror acción escenas
memorables protagonistas carismáticos y
lo que personalmente me llama más a mí
la atención sus criaturas horripilantes
pero de alguna manera geniales primeros
clásicos zombies hasta esta cosa las
criaturas de los recién tribus siempre
han sido caracterizadas por ser
visualmente asombrosas a la par que
letales que nos recuerda a los lakers
con su lengua enorme saca de lo que
parece ser la retorcida mente japonesa
alguien los hunters o lo que nos
concierne en el vídeo de hoy los taitas
aquellas enormes criaturas humanoides
que nos perseguirán constantemente lo
largo de los distintos títulos negándose
a morir los infelices mutando una y otra
y otra y otra vez siempre regresando más
desagradables que su última mutación
estas son unas de las criaturas más
emblemáticas de toda la franquicia se
conocen recién niveles más que probar y
conozcas también a los ta'yra y hoy
veremos todos los distintos modelos y
tipos de tyrone que han sido creados a
lo largo de toda la saga y que
probablemente no conozcas
pero antes de todo comencemos por una
pequeña explicación de que eso nos
traerán el por qué algunas criaturas no
están en este vídeo en los años 60
edwards ford of wall spencer y james
marcus descubrieron el virus progenitor
que digamos desde el virus madre el
virus principal que con suficiente
investigación tenía las características
de curar miles de enfermedades o incluso
la muerte trayendo la vi a los
fallecidos y con fines más macabros
crear armas biológicas letales pero este
virus resultó ser muy violento y
agresivo en los cuerpos en los que
experimentaban haciendo que ningún
cuerpo en el que experimentaran lograra
resistir los efectos del virus así que
se tomó la decisión de crear cepas de
este virus que fueran menos agresivas
con las que pudieran experimentar así
creando variantes del virus progenitor
como el virus el virus o el virus de los
tan grandes son los humanos que resultan
ser compatibles con el virus te
asimilándolo de manera exitosa en su
cuerpo pero sólo se les considera
teherán a los infectados con el virus
usted es por eso que criaturas como
birkin gustan a nuestra en este vídeo ya
que tienen en su cuerpo otras sepa el
virus progenitor
los vinos son un tema muy amplio y el
oro de recibo
si quieren que dedique un vídeo completo
comentarlo bueno ahora sí comencemos
el primer está gran del que se tiene
registro siendo el primero en su clase
es el té 001 o el llamado prototype que
aparece con un enemigo en recibir 0 este
traerán fue un humano al que debió una
sobredosis de virus te de motor aún está
gran con poca inteligencia y
coordinación lo que llevó a que lo
consideraran un fracaso al no poder
seguir órdenes y ser violentos pero
demasiado lento lo que lo hacía un
blanco vulnerable
umbrella viendo lo que un fracaso como
el pro total era capaz de hacer enfoco
todo su esfuerzo en seguir mejorando
este prototipo así creando el pez 002
que aparece en la primera entrega de la
versión en youtube el proto está gran
fue la base para este modelo mejorado
sólo que sin pasarse tanto con las bases
del virus ustedes siendo un poco más
controlada en varios objetos de prueba
que se experimentó con esta cepa del
virus usted pero sólo uno sobrevivió al
final logra no ser más ágil y fuerte
además de tener una inteligencia mayor
haciéndolo capaz de seguir órdenes
simples presenta garras grandes y
afiladas en una de sus manos además de
un segundo corazón enorme que sobresale
de su pecho para abastecer de sangre el
cuerpo ha tenido que ser todo bastante
masa muscular y un metabolismo muy
acelerado hombre la ley o la tarea
wesker de eliminar al t 002 pero a este
punto ya usted le importan un [ __ ] las
órdenes de umbrella así que decide
liberarlo para probar sus habilidades de
combate contra jill valentine y
kruijswijk frío pero alta eran
desobedecer las órdenes y mata wesker
insertándolo con sus garras
vamos ahora con los fueran más
emblemáticos sino de los más famosos el
té 103 o míster x que lo hemos
principalmente en un bulldog
pero no
este fue el primer eran suficientemente
exitoso para hombre la como para dejar
de ser un prototipo y producirlo en masa
si entonces la razón de que tenga un uno
al comienzo este taller en fue creado
hace que los del ts 002 mejorados
logrando así que tenga una apariencia
mucho más humana sin mutaciones visibles
una alta inteligencia 'no la capacidad
seguir órdenes con más eficacia
conservando gran parte de su agilidad
fuerza y velocidad este taller han a
diferencia de sus predecesores no tenéis
corazón expuesto o garras visibles
además de contar con un enorme abrigo
negro que funcionaría para reducir el
daño que reciba alta gran algo así como
una armadura ligera armadura además de
también mantener sus células controladas
y previniendo mutaciones aunque también
fue pensada para hacerlo decir más
normal aunque bueno normal normal pues
pues no vamos al gigante de casi tres
metros máximo y con la cara gris y con
piel de anciana pues muy normal no es
que sea pero van una característica de
misterio aquí es que cuando recibe una
cantidad enorme de año el virus te
comienza a mostrar reforzando las zonas
donde recibió daño pero quitándole mucha
su inteligencia convirtiendo en una
criatura que sólo quiere acabar con todo
lo que se cruce en su camino a esta
forma se le llama está gran r euríbor
[Música]
en base a míster x se desprenden los dos
siguientes style and el primero es el
trance que apareció en resident evil
outbreak file 2 creas idéntico al 303
sólo diferenciado por ser un poco más
rápido tener extremidades más flexibles
un vapor que emana de su cuerpo y nuevos
cuernos que sobresalen de su frente y
por otra parte está iván iván es una
clase de taicang usada por sergey
vladimir uno de los grandes de umbrella
como sus guardaespaldas personales
nuevamente estos son prácticamente
idénticos el míster x salvo claramente
por sus gabardinas blancas que usan y
unos lentes adheridos a su rostro que al
parecer le dan más información de su
entorno todo esto para hacerlos pasar
más desapercibidos por la sociedad
esta gran ere de 0 400 t p es otro
taller han creado base de mister x pero
está siendo más fuerte e inteligente en
su forma normal es prácticamente
idéntico mister x pero cuando recibe una
gran cantidad de daño mientras su estado
rigor sus células mutando en un aspecto
malvadísimo contando con dos enormes
garras una piel con la dureza de la roca
pero teniendo aún una gran velocidad y
agilidad a este taller han se aplicaron
medidas de seguridad implantando le una
bomba en su cuello en caso de que se
saliera de control además una cualidad
especial es que se le daban órdenes por
medio de los discos y computadoras este
taller no tenía como misión la
protección de personal en caso de un
brote viral
tánatos es una gran creada por greg
miller un científico de umbrella este
tipo quería que hubiera únicamente un
tyra en existencia el estado desacuerdo
con que se produjeran en masa pero
hombre la jamás lo escuchó así que en
desconformidad decidió librar a tánatos
un trader han creado exclusivamente para
hacer una máquina asesina su objetivo
primordial era matar él tenía el corazón
expuesto característica que pasaría a
ser muy casual en los tareas pero al
parecer para tánatos esto no sería una
debilidad aunque por si acaso se le
construyó una caja de metal para
proteger su cuerpo expuesto fue puesto a
prueba luchando contra la ub ss una
facción de umbrella dirigida
específicamente para acabar con armas
biológicas fuera de control
luego de causarle un enorme daño con c4
tánatos entra en su estado bribón donde
crece en tamaño fuerza y velocidad en
este estado se vuelve casi invencible la
única manera de acabar con él fue
inyectando de una vacuna creada para
contrarrestar el virus te llamada
daylight que acabó de una vez por todas
con tánatos vamos ahora con el 'bund'
snatch
este es un tanque de unos procesos
defectuosos y los bajos recursos para
crearlos fue considera un gran fallido
estas criaturas fueron bastantes
defectos son bastante débiles en
comparación a la era normal carl gente
su brazo izquierdo pero tienen un brazo
derecho bastante grande con la capacidad
cuidarse para sostener a sus enemigos
siguiendo con la lista vamos con el
taller ante 10 078 que es el que podemos
ver en código veronica este taller en
recibí en la isla rock por funcionó como
un tan grande entrenamiento para que las
fuerzas especiales de umbrella hallará
más maneras de lidiar con armas
biológicas de este tipo que fue liberado
para acabar con claire redfield este
taller es parecido al está eran del
primer juego con la diferencia de que
éste no tiene el corazón expuesto lo que
lo deja sin puntos débiles además de
contar con garras retráctiles
el siguiente en la lista es el ts 091
que nos encontraremos en resident evil
dead en este taller aún fue algo así
como una prueba al realizar un taller
and con un nuevo y volátil virus que era
una mezcla entre el virus y el virus je
pero hacer un prototipo fue bastante
defectuoso mutando descontroladamente
dado a esta mezcla de las dos cepas del
virus así logra no tener esa apariencia
tan extraña además de tener garras sino
tentáculos en sus dedos de manera
bastante usual no estarán teniendo su
cuerpo expuesto sólo que esta vez
sobresaliendo a la espalda
del mismo juego de james podemos
encontrar también al siguiente
contendiente pluto estero criminal
condenado a muerte al que se le hicieron
operaciones y experimentos con el
mutando lo con el virus de este llegó a
ser parcialmente un tyra no pudo
completar su transformación ya que
debido a varias drogas que se
suministraron y tratamientos indebidos
desarrolló mucha grasa corporal en vez
de musculatura como los demás tareas
quedó panxón para aliviar su dolor se le
introdujo una barra de metal en su
lóbulo frontal además de que se le
removieron quirúrgicamente sus ojos
guiándose únicamente por el sonido que
hacen sus enemigos
morpheus dual funes e investigador de
umbrella despedido después de los
incidentes de la mansión spencer en 1998
resentido y con ganas de vengarse morfeo
robot de los laboratorios de los virus
te dije inyectándose los asimismo hace
logrando una mutación muy controlada
permitiéndole conservar su inteligencia
recuerdos y cualidades humanas casi
completas además de ser único está gran
del que se tiene registro que tenga una
forma femenina morfeo sen está
transformacional similar de manera
exitosa el virus que y te logra crear
una especie de energía eléctrica que usa
para atacar además de tener los
atributos físicos de un titán y
sorprendentemente tener la habilidad de
hablar comúnmente su fallo es que al
recibir una gran cantidad de daño el
virus que comienza a mutar
convirtiéndolo en esta cosa
antes de seguir con los talleres más
comunes que va a ser un paréntesis para
mencionar un par de enemigos que no
tiene el virus usted como tal pero
tienen cepas de este mismo comenzando
con nigel fisher este tipo aparecen en
tracción y would revelations 2 si es un
miembro de un grupo antiterrorismo que
resulta ser un traidor en el transcurso
del juego álex pues que una hermana de
west que lo infecta con el virus de
fobos que es una cepa del virus ted
creada por la misma álex wesker esta
cepa es más agresiva se dejan las
víctimas de este virus en un estado
pasivo pero se dispara y se propaga por
el cuerpo con emociones intensas como el
miedo además de esto sumándole luro boro
esto convierte a niell en una enorme
criatura multada combina nuestros dos
virus
luego tenemos a la misma álex wesker que
al enfrentarse a barry y verse superada
decidió que no quería morir sin
trascender al igual que lo visual ver
wesker ellos son la misma combinación de
teléfonos con eurobonos que en su
encuentro con barry y natalia en
revelations 2 la hizo mutar en esta
criatura siendo muy así partiendo un
cuerpo grande y con movimientos algo
torpes
ya para finalizar con esto se me está
grande tenemos a jack normal el jefe
final de resident evil revelations este
hombre es el líder de una organización
bio terrorista conocida como velcro al
verse acorralado por cris vertió hierba
lenta y no le queda otra opción que es
una muestra concentrada del virus de
aves en sí mismo que es una cepa del
virus t mejorada base de adn de
criaturas marinas cuando inyectó este
virus se convirtió en esta enorme
criatura que es uno de mis elementos
favoritos de toda la saga es que mira
luego es precioso el hijo de tu nombrado
último elvis éste está en cuenta con una
fisionomía distinta a la de los demás
está gran teniendo características más
asociadas con la vida marina como esas
garras en su mano izquierda además de
contar con un enorme ojo en el centro de
su rostro que le permite crear ilusiones
a voluntad y transportarse a cualquier
parte del escenario
ya siguiendo con los demás tenemos a
himnos himnos es un está gran común algo
más pequeño el usual y con un aspecto
joven y humanoide lo que lo diferencia
de los demás es que junto al virus td se
le agregó el gen hypnos que es una
cadena genética que cuando se implanta
en el portador comienza por medio
selección natural a acabar con las
células más débiles de su cuerpo dejando
son las células más fuertes así
repitiendo este proceso una y otra vez
fomentando así el desarrollo de células
cada vez más fuertes
volviéndose cada vez más poderoso pero
así como sus hermanos traerán libros al
recibir una gran cantidad de daño mutar
a una forma más bestial y primitiva que
lo hará vulnerable
[Música]
el taller en parasitario es un taller
han aparecido en operación raccoon city
es como mí estaré aquí espero controlado
por un parásito cosa que causó que este
parásito controlara todo su sistema
nervioso y de alguna manera lo hiciera
más fuerte haciéndolo mutar tanto alta
eran como el parásito e incluso dándole
la habilidad de comandar zombies para
que te ataquen
después tenemos al tailandés 013 que
hace su operación la película de
resident evil dead nation esta es quizás
uno de los modelos más fuertes y
mejorados hasta la fecha siendo
físicamente parecidos a mestre x pero
más veloces fuertes y con la capacidad
de seguir órdenes a la perfección estos
talleres fueron usados por svetlana
bélico en las repúblicas la oriental
para ser usados como armas en la guerra
civil que se libraba en ese momento
contra los rebeldes éstos traerán son
demasiado fuertes deshaciéndose de los
lakers como si fueran simples moscas en
serio me en la película y les doy mi
palabra' que en un punto llegué a sentir
pena por los lakers al ser destrozados
por siesta eran ni un líder más
[Música]
en fin además de esa fuerza sobrehumana
su limitador es decir su gabardina negra
resiste más daño pero cuando se destruye
y él te 013 muta su mutación es algo
parecida a la de mister x solo que ahora
tiene garras afiladas en ambas manos
además de que su corazón no está
expuesto dándole una gran ventaja éstos
traerán son extremadamente veloces y
resistentes siendo lo único que puede
acabar con ellos es un disparo
quemarropa de un [ __ ] tanque o de
aviones de combate
el siguiente es uno de los traerán más
avanzados vistos en toda la serie con
unos proyectos mejor seguidos y
financiados hablo de talos por sus
siglas en inglés estarán armor litro
organic sister o sistema traerán
blindado orgánico letal curioso que
tenga letal en su nombre como si los
demás atrás no lo fueran no soy yo
seguro la pasé muy bien con némesis no
es para nada letal jugamos manitas
calientes colocadora en fin esta
bestialidad de tyrone fue creado viendo
la efectividad que tuvo el proyecto en
némesis teniendo el propósito de ser el
arma biológica más peligrosa jamás
creada jehová ya que lo lograron ya que
no siento suficiente con suavice más
fuerza y resistencia de una gran
velocidad y agilidad talos puede ser
fácilmente manejado mediante un chip o
implantado dentro de sí dándole órdenes
por medio una computadora
este taller era capaz de manejar armas
tal como el lanzacohetes enorme que
maneja en su primera etapa hasta lo se
le otorgó una armadura blindada para
prevenir mutaciones descontroladas en su
cuerpo pero lograba que christie 10 lo
enfrentarán por la armadura valió madres
ya que mostró un enorme criatura mucho
más fuerte pero menos inteligente
bueno bueno bueno ya como último puesto
en esta lista tenemos al mejor al alfa y
el omega el tide and the titans tu papá
némesis este es mi enemigo favorito de
toda la franquicia y estoy seguro que el
favorito de muchos otros y como no si es
que se hermosa un mírale es perfecto
depredador silencioso mismo las de meses
como ya saben es el antagonista
principal del recital y wood 3 siendo
éste una de las mejores creaciones de
umbrella hasta la fecha este taller fue
enviado a raccoon city para acabar con
los miembros restantes de stars que
pueden ser una amenaza para hombre la
némesis es la evolución del test ciento
300 entera en el que se le inyectó el
parásito en némesis alfa directamente en
el cerebro de ahí su famosa cicatriz
este parásito aumenta las habilidades
físicas del tayrona además de dotarlo
con inteligencia necesaria como para
seguir órdenes complejas y manipular
varios tipos de armas como
ametralladoras y lanzacohetes o como
pudimos ver en el remake de res en
tribus 3 también un lanzallamas porta un
acabar dina negra que fuese una igual
que con mister x como su limitador
previniendo mutaciones aunque con
suficiente daño el parásito se saldrá de
control dándole así mutaciones con un
aspecto cada vez menos humano estos son
los estarán más feroces más tenaces más
letales y sin duda alguna uno de los más
geniales
y bueno hasta la lista de todos los
padres que en la saga de resident evil
de aumento en futuros juegos habrá más
criaturas con las cuales enviarnos a
tiros comenta partículas es mejor está
grande esta asombrosa saga ya veremos en
futuros juegos en criaturas aún más
grotescas y geniales para agregar esta
lista hasta la próxima
[Música]